[Music]
was our first feature Point Break did we
do that before rumors not officially yet
right so as a company tremors would be
the first technically the cash future a
gas I don't know someone should Google
that are you going to ask us questions
or did you wants to start talking did
you introduce each other I would love to
I would like to introduce you to Tom
Woodruff jr. who is the co-founder of
amalgamated dynamics I'd like to
introduce you to Alec Gillis he's the
co-founder of Adi home of the
oscar-winning creature effects team when
people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non
computer-generated characters we've been
lucky to be involved with some of the
biggest and best of those types of
monsters we did the worms and tremors we
did a fad makeups of Tim Allen in the
Santa Clause all the practical animals
in Jumanji we've done the alien we've
done the predator Starship Troopers I
wasn't done you can keep going buddy and
of course there's always the gorilla cut
right now that's perfect right that now
we cut putting the gorilla costume we
sort of perform your own creatures
because we both have this sort of
observation of stuntmen despite their
talents and their skills them going into
a creature suit and not really knowing
how to make a creature suit work it
would be very weird for us to just say
we're going to build something and then
bring it to set and say now what are you
hungry
want some Flutie you hungry if you're a
digital animator you build the character
and you follow through and you make it
move and you bring it to life so that's
our philosophy is the final step is
performance because that's where it
lives you want to try a little tiny
piece here go ahead
and what do you think you want some more
you hey hey listen listen I can get you
fresh bread
I can I can get you fresh bread tremors
is an example of a film that was from
the pre-digital era and if you look at
it the practical effects they've stood
the test of time and we're proud of that
digital effects can do things that we
can't possibly do practical effects have
a presence to them that even the best
CGI work gets close to but doesn't
completely achieve in other words
there's more emotion I believe to a
practical creature than to a digital
creature
wave to the camera and say goodbye bye
bye bye
he's so temperamental
[Music]